and hi my name is Dobrin lee and i'm the
CEO of net hope and we just completed a
panel on smarter cities and urbanization
and we found three key elements that we
thought were critical in terms of
findings and next steps the first is is
it a good idea and we had panelists that
we're looking at both pre fields and
brownfield situations we have massive
project in Saudi Arabia a king fahd city
a hundred billion dollar project from
scratch de novo secondly we had
Barcelona and a project there to sort of
Regent refine injects smart city type
concepts into a city that's been around
for hundreds of years so a challenge of
the in between those two what are the
learnings what are the things and first
of all is it a good idea when you look
at smart cities well could those two
poles but also done the very practical
level in terms of villages in small ways
that we can make an impact in terms of
the environment and society and the
human capital so the first question is
is it a good idea whatever that means
the stakeholders involved the second is
do we have the resources to pull it off
do we have whatever resources we need
certainly financial resources but also
the human resources and kind of
everything in between the business and
the government and other kinds of
resources that are neither in order to
make the new model for organization for
the future come about you need resources
for that a well-funded venture tends to
succeed and funding however that's
defined whether it's on the basic level
or at the high end government funding
you've got to have resources and the
faith finding we came out of our panel
on smarter cities was you need and
probably the most critical is you need
leadership you may have technocrats and
managers and people who can engineer and
Bill but you need vision you need
leadership and because these projects at
large and small big projects and those
are very very micro you still needs a
leadership we need people who are going
to carry the flame and keep things
moving even when you hit your blogs and
obstacles so from our panel just now on
our cities and mobilization we found
that those were the three things is it a
good idea we have the resources to pull
it off and we have the leadership for
the future we found our panel was rich
with leaders and we want to cultivate
that for the future